hi I'm Jimmy Fallon I'm here at BuzzFeed
and I'm here to answer questions and
play with puppies Oh No
hi oh hi oh my god oh hi do you think
there's a tree in there they're getting
out of control
okay they're going why help me answer
questions which one do you want which
one should I go for I'm gonna get my
hand in it okay yeah don't jump in the
job okay oh here it says do you have
code names for celebrity friends so that
you can talk about them I don't think so
really no I know some people do on their
phones I think if anyone ever hacked in
my phone they just see everyone's name
so Timberlake watch out because
someone's gonna get your number come
here oh hi guys oh my gosh Carrie look
at this come on out kiddo don't you eat
that question yeah you can beat my
sweater go oh that was a good one what
show do your kids watch it drives you
crazy gosh we go through all sorts of
phases of annoying shows but I'm kind of
kind of missed them now cuz you're
growing up and so I kind of missed those
annoying shows but Teletubbies is the
trip I really don't quite understand
that show it's so bizarre I don't it's
like an acid trip it is uh yeah so I
thought I would say Teletubbies guys
come here come on go for another
question okay good you know okay yeah
you're gonna do it look he's opening
himself who was the guest on your show
that made you laugh the hardest I
laughed so many times on my show Will
Ferrell was always fun Bradley Cooper
and I did an interview where we couldn't
even finish the interview because he was
we were laughing so hard because we were
wearing these dumb wigs and we were
talking about something kind of serious
and it's just look those giggles that
you get like if you're in school or
church and we just couldn't stop
giggling and we try to restart and edit
it and we couldn't get together I think
the interview is 25 minutes long of us
laughing it's on YouTube and it's pretty
addictive look at this doggies face are
you kidding me hi hi
which person from the roots would you
most like to have hosted show four day I
think James would be fun I'd like to see
James host he's a pretty funny dude
they're all they're all funny dudes but
James you host and I'll play the thank
you note music
we're all running away is it my clone
[Music]
which one which one oh look at that oh
that's the one this weird or what is
your favorite SNL sketch that you were
part of we have the sketch called
more cowbell um we did on sent live but
and Will Ferrell was one of my first
sketch I was ever in and Will Ferrell
was just so funny in the sketch and him
and katana were playing around in the
sketch it Christopher Walken was extra
walkin II you know he was talking like
not even he was doing an impression of
himself really and Catana Willa fooling
around and Catana quills sunglasses huh
and I saw the eyes of a lunatic and I've
lost it had one line to say and I
screwed it up and started laughing and
there was like you can't laugh I go it
was so funny and they go you're in the
sketch idiot you can't laugh at your
your own sketch I got I know I'm just
starting I'm out of my league of so that
was the probably the best cast I find
out one of these dogs my wife is gonna
kill me but I own with the outcome one
come on eat my sweater
are you eating my sweater are you eating
like various alright alright
you've never made it in the
entertainment business what career do
you think you'd be doing today it's a
good question you know my parents are
very supportive of my comedy career but
I remember after college they made me
take the postal exam to become a mailman
because just fall back on in case the
comedy created and take off and I I
nailed it I crushed that the Postal Exam
and so uh I would love being a moment I
love mail men and women mail people I
love that they wear shorts I love that
they kind of they drive with the
steering wheel on the other side of the
vehicle they got like their own rules
you know no real no real set time they
just show up be everyone respects to
that man because he's bring you good
news you know so you want to take care
of your mailman so I think I'd like that
and there's all these two toys here but
nothing is better than a finger a human
finger all right here we go
you're stranded on a desert island with
four of your past guests who would you
want beside you
who wouldn't want I somebody could guess
at them so uh Justin Timberlake
cuz he's funny he could sing ariana
grande Demi Lovato's fun Michelle Obama
I mean everyone's invited whoever wants
to be on the deserted island with me I
mean wow
that's like I'm the answer to like some
of the who do would you not want to be
in a deserted island
I'm on that list okay these are hot dogs
so give me a little puppy attack dogs oh
wow this is like a this is like an
actual paw patrol right now this is a
live-action paw patrol my kids be so
jealous right now
chase Marshall Skye who was the last
famous person you texted PS you're the
Beth hey thanks you're the best post
Malone
I just told me did great at the Grammy
Awards I love that guy posted he calls
me Dad all that bad guys focus up
puppies
focus look later I'm just gonna get down
with them okay
all right here we go let's do the
question like this all right okay here
we go
it says can't really read all right if
you're if you had your own planet what
would it be named and which five items
would you bring on the planet I would
name it Animal Planet and I would just
to have a lawsuit with Animal Planet and
I get to probably meet Judge Judy
I like care of a fan first and then what
what five items would I bring I would
bring these four puppies and and in an
instant pop but not to cut the puppies
out to feed them because ever you can
make anything in an instant pop all
right guys here we go you just received
lots of thank-you notes what is your
favorite thank-you note that you've
received um I got one from David
Letterman recently hi guys
because I sent out avvocato toast for
the holidays and he sent me a thank-you
note saying thanks for the guacamole
kiss it's not what I sent him at all how
did your amazing friendship with Justin
Timberlake start what's the craziest
thing you two have ever done together I
met him on seront live he was in in sync
and then I hosted the VMAs and the Video
Music Awards and he was going solo for
the first time yeah I know it was a
great solo and that we were both nervous
and then we both did well that night I
wouldn't friends ever since was the
craziest thing me and Justin I've ever
done we broke into a house we thought it
was an open house I'm gonna go look at
it and turns out there was no one there
and then one of the doors was open so we
just figured well let's just go ahead
and look at it anyway so he just kind of
broke into a house I was like this
person ever knew that we crashed their
house what's the favorite part of your
job what's the least favorite part
favorite part of my jobs I get to make
people laugh that's the greatest with
today's world with the internet and
everything it's just it's bigger than
the United States it's bigger than you
know which is amazing but it's global
and you get to see fans and hear
reaction from fans all over the world
and that's the greatest part and not
just like laughing but like ugly face
ugly laughing face really the least part
of my job least part I don't really have
I just kind of very very lucky to have
this job it's a good job Oh
ah she's got smell so good - hi puppy
what's your favorite game to do on the
show we play lots of games in the show
my favorite games is we love impressions
where we have different guests come on
if they do an impression of somebody
we'll have them do that person and and
sing a famous nursery rhyme or somebody
that Ariana Grande's been on she's out a
couple times and been fantastic
Christina Aguilera did a great one you
should check them out they're really
really talented any time you could see a
celebrity doing something besides
selling their movie or whatever I always
like that on the show what town where
last question eat it don't eat it let me
answer it first on the spot create the
weirdest version of a Shawn Mendes song
using different voice pitches Oh puppies
crazy and bets they will be sniffing and
all they will be fetching there's no way
I'm taking all of these back I'm leaving
with these puppies thank you so much for
BuzzFeed thank you so much to all these
great puppies and North Shore Animal
League America thank you so much these
puppies are available adopt a puppy
thank you so much for watching guys bye
[Music]